- Hi everyone, my name is Vig.
- And I'm Juan.
We are your senior class officers.
Welcome to the Class Day 2020 experience.
- First and foremost,
we really hope everyone
is safe and healthy.
This is obviously not what we envisioned
when we pictured the
end of our time at Yale.
These last few weeks were
supposed to be some of the best
and instead they've been
some of the toughest.
But those lost weeks
will not be what defines
the Class of 2020.
No, we're the class that
pressed on in spite of the virus
and all the barriers that it brought.
We made TikToks, had Zoom happy hours,
we passionately advocated for UP.
More than that, we had an incredible
3.75 years together on campus
and stayed together virtually
in that last quarter.
We are still connected
despite the physical distance
that this pandemic has forced on us.
We will not be the class that
simply lost our senior spring,
but instead the one that persevered
through all the adversity that we faced.
- Our time at Yale has been
marked by momentous change.
We are among the last first
years to experience Commons
in all its traditions and glory,
and we will hopefully be the last class
to hear jokes that TD is so far.
We were the first to
have Heads of College,
first years, and Hopper College.
Yale Memes for Special Snowflake Teens
was founded when we got here.
We were witness to the
unforgettable month of November 2016
when we won our first
Harvard-Yale game in 10 years
and then went on to win two more.
- Then senior year happened
and we learned how much
this class loved to party.
We kicked things off with Opening Night
and we had two open bars.
But we realized we needed
to upgrade pretty soon.
And so we did, to 12 at Masquerade.
We had Oktoberfest
a month after Oktoberfest
is supposed to happen,
and we finished things off
with our Wine and Cheese Night
at the Yale Center for British Art
which is definitely the kind of event
that I expected to have more of at Yale.
And before you ask, I'm sorry,
it is too late to get your senior sticker.
- All of those big moments
would not have been complete
without the smaller ones.
From Junzi late night, staying
way too long at the Buttery,
"Living on a Prayer" to close out Woads,
to IMs, the bonds we formed
and the memories we made together
will be what define our time at Yale.
From academics to clubs,
residential colleges and the arts,
cultural centers and athletic teams,
there are people and
friendships that have helped us
through Yale and will continue to help us
throughout our lives.
This is how our class will be remembered.
- So congratulations to the Class of 2020.
We are so excited to see
what the future holds for all of us.
Even though our in-person celebration
is gonna have to wait a little bit,
we can graduate knowing
that we have each other
to help us get there.
And when we do, I think we're gonna need
to have more than 12 open bars.
- In the meantime, we
will continue to celebrate
your hard work despite this change.
We'll now move on to
the Class Day committee
who have worked tirelessly to modify
the traditional Class Day experience
to make it special for a class
that deserves nothing less.
- Thanks Vig and Juan.
To the Class of 2020, on behalf of myself,
Ananya, Calvin, Nathan, and Sarah,
we just wanna say congratulations.
The past couple of years have been filled
with so many fantastic
memories and experiences
that only feel sweeter to us now.
We've worked really
hard over the past year
to craft a celebration of
the amazing experiences,
accomplishments, friendships, and bonds
that we've built together as a class
and we are so excited to
showcase the amazing work
of our classmates to you this week.
This year being virtual,
we've done our best to revamp
the Class Day experience
to make it more accessible
to you all and your families,
regardless of where you are in the world.
- So instead of Class Day,
this year we're excited
to be expanding this tradition
into a week-long celebration
we're calling Class Week.
Each day this week we
will be releasing a video
covering a portion of the
typical Class Day elements.
These videos will be
posted at 2:30 p.m. Eastern
under the Class Day tab
of the Yale Commencement 2020
website, yale2020.yale.edu.
Because this is happening
over the course of a week,
we hope you will stay engaged every day
and join us in celebrating
our amazing class.
- Each portion of the
ceremony will have its own day
and we have a little preview
of all the exciting
content coming your way.
On Tuesday, we begin the week
with Joy Qiu's "Serious Reflection,"
as she thinks about what
Yale has meant to her
and about what graduating
means to all of us.
On Wednesday, Simon Fraser
and Oscar Lopez-Aguirre will present us
with their extremely funny
"Comedic Reflection."
On Thursday, Vincent Vaughns
will give us his "Ivy Ode,"
an inspiring call to all of
us to recognize our dreams
and fight for them.
Come Friday, Dean Chun
will offer his remarks
to the Class of 2020.
And after that we suggest
that you grab some Kleenex
in preparation for the
next item on the agenda
which is the class history slideshow.
On Saturday, we have an
exciting toast prepared
with some very special guests.
And finally, on Sunday, we end
with the week with an address
from our esteemed guest
speaker, Dr. Jean Bennett,
the Class of 1976.
- As Sarah walked us through the schedule,
you can see that we've
adapted certain traditions
of the Class Day ceremony.
The virtual format lends
itself to week-long festivities
that we can all enjoy together.
In our virtual ceremony
we've found some traditions
work very well while others
are harder to replicate.
During most years, students and speakers
sport homemade hats during the ceremony.
This year however, we encourage you
to dedicate your time and supplies
to making masks for your friends,
families, and communities.
We've learned time and time again at Yale
that the small actions matter.
Right now, we can make that difference
with this small action.
Whether you decide to make masks or hats,
please share your progress
with the class on social media
using the hashtag #Yale2020.
And we will be sure to include hats
in our future in-person ceremony.
We are also shipping a
Class Day care package
with the physical items from
a typical Class Day ceremony
and some new additions.
Look forward to that.
- We have an exciting week planned ahead
and we cannot wait to
share it with all of you.
While this is not how we
expected to spend our last week,
we hope that this celebration
is able to bring together
the Class of 2020, bridging
social distance and lost time
to the extent possible.
We hope that your family,
friends, and loved ones
are able to join us to celebrate
our class' achievements,
memories, and friendships.
We encourage you to share the link
to the Yale Commencement website with them
and to remember to use
the hashtag #Yale2020
to share your thoughts
and emotions as you watch.
Thank you all for joining us this week.
We hope that you are safe and healthy
and we are sending you all our love,
support, and congratulations.